what's the deal with everything peanuts
peanuts from owning a sandwich shop our
sandwiches taste better they feel better
they're priced better but don't take my
word for it ask some of our happy
customers
and if you still don't believe me go to
Subway but we know where that can lead
to producing rap albums when I was in
sixth grade that was when I first
started to rap and my rap name was uh
Cracker Jack
Joe DeRosa is unlike any other comedian
in the game and yesterday we had a
chance to talk with Joe about releasing
his new album right before hitting the
road for his biggest comedy tour yet I'd
say most people watching this interview
know you mainly from the comedy world
but you also had a brand new music album
come out last week called artificial
birth how long has that been in the work
and how often are you working on music
in general so uh the band is called
Salsa windfall and and uh it's me and my
buddy Paul Chell and we started doing
this back when I was still in college we
recorded our first songs on a four track
we never necessarily stopped recording
uh but we eventually did stop playing
out and we stopped releasing stuff in
any way because we just kind of he
became a chef and and I started doing
comedy and as your lives go on you know
we lived in different cities I moved to
New York he moved to uh to New World to
New Orleans and um it was just kind of
hard to find a way to have any footing
with it you know but it was something we
liked to do and every year or other year
when we would get together we would
still record stuff and you know would it
what what ended up happening was we had
recorded a whole record this this this
artificial Birth album years ago I was
living in L.A and we recorded it in LA
in my apartment and then we had our
friend James pinkstone Master it and mix
it for us and it sounded really good we
were really proud of it but we were just
like what are we gonna do with it you
know like who are we gonna put it out to
like so we didn't do anything with it
we've been sitting on it for about eight
years and then and it all kind of
resurfaced on my podcast taste buds and
then the fans started commenting and
writing and asking about the band and
that snowball just kind of kept going
and uh I said to Paul hey I actually
think we could put the album out finally
and we did and um here we are just came
out last week it charted on iTunes I
can't believe it like it's like wild
everything that kind of dropped last
week and and it is happening now this
week and moving forward with the band it
was stuff that was all just kind of
ruminating for a very long time and now
it's finally here and um we're gonna
keep doing stuff the band name is salsa
windfall like you've mentioned already I
don't know if you saw the clip of this
last hey babe episode with Chris and Sal
where they're listening to the song you
put out and they're trying to figure out
what the name salsa windfall even means
I think someone said it sounds like a
burrito buffet in Orlando the name of
his band is salsa windfall I I did he
ever explain that wait wait hold on a
second stop this that little
that sounds like a burrito place in
Orlando yeah does the name actually mean
anything or how did you and Paul come up
with that Paul came up with it we were
in the apartment I remember we were just
we were a young man and we we got a
bunch of weed weed was a really special
thing back then you know it's not like
now where it just falls out of every
tree you walk by getting your hands on
weed and getting to use it and smoke it
was was awesome and special and we we
had a bunch of weed and we had a bunch
of I don't know beer or some kind of
liquor and he said we should record
while we were there and he was starting
to get into cooking and he was like I'll
cook and he made this big uh Mexican
spread one night it was like tacos and
all kinds of stuff we were a few songs
in and I was like what do you think we
should call this and he's like we should
call it salsa wind fall he was holding a
jar salsa and I was like okay my
vocabulary was so poor I didn't even
know what the word windfall meant yeah
yeah I thought it was a fart joke and
then like like months later he's like no
when means like a lot I was like oh
it means like you know like we have a
windfall of you know uh hamburgers or
whatever it's a ton of hamburger that's
awesome that it seems like this is just
so much of a passion project for you
like you didn't even have any plans for
anyone else to hear it besides you and
Paul it sounds like but you just want to
do it anyway which I feel like is really
authentic and and cool and one of the
things that I feel like makes you one of
the most interesting people in comedy
because you have this music side you
have the stand-up side and then you also
on top of that obviously own your
sandwich shop in New York city so I
gotta ask you this question I feel like
it's pretty obvious but [__] Mary kill
between stand-up comedy making music and
Joey roses well thank you for all that
it was very nice what you just said I
mean I'd [__] Joey roses because it's
it's you know it's fun being in the bar
and sandwich business but it's a
different kind of work that I hadn't
been used to in a long time it's not the
Arts it's like no it's a business
there's a building there and he needs to
make money anyway so it's fun it's fun
to dip into I love the brand and I love
what we're doing but the business part
of it is not my favorite thing to live
and breathe every day yeah but I am
attracted to it I want to [__] it
I mean I'd marry uh the the band only
because you know I listened to music and
every day you know constantly not con
but consistently I don't listen to stand
up every day you know right so I guess
I'd have to kill stand up but we had a
good run 23 years like if you know
whatever like so as one of the few
comedians with real legitimate musical
Talent have you ever done the goddamn
Comedy Jam and if so have you ever
considered playing one of your own songs
I've done it many times I was supposed
to do the very first one they ever did
and I couldn't do it I was I was living
in La at the time I was booked for it
and I got stuck out in New York I forget
why I was in New York but I couldn't
leave and I called Josh and said I'm
sorry I can't do that show where you
want us to sing the songs or whatever he
didn't have a name for it yet and then I
so I did the second one and on the
second one I did Power of Love by Huey
Lewis in the news and and then I was
I've been a part of it ever since I do
The Comedy Jam all the time but no I
would never do my own like if there were
some like
demand for it I would do it like I
wouldn't be an [__] about it but like
no I wouldn't do it like like I should
do that yeah that seems awfully
indulgent yeah all right last question
here uh and then I'll let you go I've
heard you mention a few times that your
your tour current tour I've Never
Promised You a Rose Garden is one man's
show ask or I'm gonna show like what
exactly does that mean in terms of what
comedy fans should expect when coming to
see you out on the road I mean it's a
very themed show there's a real spine to
it from start to finish
you know it's described when we were we
we were running it at the crane theater
in New York you know workshopping it
and the um
the play Bill said it just said welcome
to an hour of hopeless comedy because
it's the the theme of the show is is
hopelessness it's funny all the way
through it never gets like too serious
but like it's about hopelessness it's
about like
the deterioration of of the social
fabric that used to kind of hold us
together and like and and being under
the
uh influence of of charlatans and you
know how it's all you know the the
illusions of progress and people you
know the the the illusion of Tolerance
and the you know the the great illusion
that everybody likes to pretend they're
all living on on these social platforms
that they're that they're just so
tolerant and they're just so Progressive
and they're just so this they're so that
it's all [__] and the title just
kind of Suits it like I I you know I I
kind of call it uh like I the you
Trilogy I did three hours now that were
themed that I had the the term you in
them okay the first was an album called
you will die it had the the second disc
of that so that was double album but the
first album was just the hour Set uh and
then the second disc was me trying to do
the set in in front of a bad audience
and bombing and like literally fighting
the audience the entire time and these
three hours you know the U is the scent
is really the key word because it's it's
it's really pointing the finger outward
this is the problem with you people
you know uh so that one certainly does
it the second one was called you let me
down and the title says it all like you
know I I sort of believed in all of this
and it was [__] and it let me down
and now this third one I Never Promised
You a Rose Garden because it's it's
about it's because there's there's a
real as as heavy as it all kind of
sounds there's a shoulder shrug to all
of it I'm not up there going and we need
to do better I'm going I'm going it's
[__] people and it's not gonna get any
better like hey no nobody promised you
anything better than this so I guess
here we are you know um so that's that's
kind of the idea of these three and I
always wanted to complete the arc and I
feel like this one does complete the ark
and and then the next one maybe move on
to something brighter and I appreciate
uh you having a conversation with me
here today uh where should people check
out artificial birth
um is that iTunes is that YouTube uh
yeah yeah it's for sale on iTunes salsa
windfall artificial birth that's on sale
on iTunes and band camp you know but but
it's streaming on All Digital platforms
Apple music Spotify the single is called
mouth on my money the video for mouth on
my money you can see on the no pressure
Channel on YouTube which is also where
you can check out taste buds my podcast
we'll see you and how it's available on
uh on the back catalogs out there
somewhere but all the new apps are on
patreon and finally this tour is is
about to start in September doing this
new show it's very themed it's dark but
I swear to God it's funny uh and we're
hitting Jersey uh Phoenix Toronto Philly
Salt Lake City a ton of places and we're
still adding dates and you can get all
of that info and the ticket Links at
joederrosa.com thank you man really
appreciate it thanks yeah thanks buddy
I'll talk to you soon appreciate it Matt
mccusker dropped his new special on
YouTube last Wednesday and comedy fans
could not be more excited titled the
speed of light Matt released this hour
of stand-up comedy completely
unannounced in this new age of Comedy
it's almost the industry standard for
guys with new specials to go on as many
podcasts as they possibly can to promote
but the shaman put this thing up with
basically no press he's already well
over 800 000 views speaking of gay guys
I uh
I have a food allergy
I have a gluten allergy dude it sucks I
know it sucks
my uncles all give me [__] they're like
you just do this gluten stuff for
attention it's like it's like the only
attention I get is you guys calling me a
[__] that's I don't want that the speed
of light was directed by John McKeever
and opens up with a hilarious scene of
Matt rollerblading through the streets
of Philadelphia where do you go tennis
court
the rollerblade yeah yeah right
I'm not that kind of blader bro dude
rollerblading on a tennis Court's the
best very smooth surface yeah I was
doing grassy Hills it was pretty sick oh
damn that's real I'm cross country dude
it was I I'm filming I'm filming a
rollerblading intro for my special oh
really yeah so I was like I'll hop on
the blades get some footage I got on it
like we started at 10 o'clock so I
showed up at 9 40 to practice dude I was
so bad yeah rollerblading forever sure
stopping is the hardest part yeah unless
you have the brake on the heel dude
I would just like find grass and jump
into it to stop yeah that's the best
move yeah it was dude it was my favorite
part is you jumping from the hill
if you haven't seen it yet definitely
check out the speed of light right after
this video at this point I've only
watched the first 30 minutes or so just
because I'm seeing Matt mccusker live
this Thursday and I don't know how much
overlap there's gonna be but we'll
probably make a video recapping comedy
fans reactions to the special later this
week so be sure to keep an eye out for
that also side note if anyone watching
this is friends with Matt please tell
them to check his Instagram DM so I can
try to interview him while he's in Tampa
thank you guest spots from last week The
Joe Rogan Experience at I'm Brian Callan
and Patrick back David two bears one
cave was Tom and Theo Vaughn Giannis
Papas was on are you garbage Giannis was
also on the voice cast as well as bad
friends kill Tony this week was with Jim
Norton ymh talked with Sarah Tiana
flagrant did not have a guest we might
be drunk talked with Nick Griffin Mark
Norman was on stabi's world and Matt and
Shane talked with Dan Soder and Nate
Marshall have you ever go into Europe
they just don't have air conditioning
yeah it's just like a wet but it's hot
down there now right now
you're watching a bunch of Scottish
people being like oh thought is going to
be green
because there's a guy in my neighborhood
that walks with his dog obviously I've
never done that joke I stopped doing
that joke after like three months yeah
people don't like that joke no they
don't talk about whooping dogs in
Scotland I would walk through every day
to go to my shows I'd walk through this
giant Park all the dogs are off leash
yeah crazy all the dogs are off leash
and the Scottish dude I'm smoking a
joint with they go man how are the dogs
so well behaved here and just a matter
of fact he goes beat the [__] out of
them oh okay this past weekend with you
Yvonne had on YG whiskey Ginger spoke
with Kevin [__] the blocks podcast
talked with Fortune feamster Anthony
Bowens was a guest on Chrissy chaos
taste buds battled sore throat verse
stuffy nose Alex Hooper was on the
Honeydew Whitney Cummings was on first
date Jade Kate uprida was the guest on
the Harland Highway Being Ian with
Jordan had on cousin Cheryl and Mike
Racine and tigerbelly had on fluffy as
far as new stand-up specials go that are
out right now besides the speed of light
Jim Gaffigan's 10th special is out on
Amazon Prime video Mark Norman Soup To
Nuts is available right now on Netflix
and there's also a new stand up on the
spot that debuted yesterday on YouTube
if you're a fan of crowd work also this
has nothing to do with new specials but
I just wanted to mention that kill Tony
changed their YouTube profile picture
and it looks so much better now in my
opinion but let me know if you guys
agree thanks again to Joe DeRosa for
coming on the show this week and also to
all the loyal subscribers who helped get
him here we just posted a new video on
this channel titled comedians vs
hecklers and it includes some of the
craziest moments in stand-up comedy
history which you can find on the end
screen right after this video thanks for
watching
at joke world
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out